on today's show we talked to a man whose
32 year old brother
still lives at home with mom and dad we
talked to a woman whose husband is
addicted to cocaine and alcohol
and we talked to an awesome woman in
houston texas
who's a mom a wife and a nurse
and she's trying to make it all work
stay tuned
hey what's up it's stelony with the dr
john dolone show we're glad you're here
i'm glad you're here kelly's not i am
i'm glad you're here
there's eight trillion podcasts you can
be listening to or youtube channels
you can be watching and i'm glad you're
with us i'm glad you chose this one
on this show we take your calls about
your life these are real people
unscripted real folks with real
challenges going on they give us a shout
and we walk alongside
anybody struggling with anything from
education issues to
family and parenting to marriage to
my kids my brothers my sisters mental
health challenges all of it
everybody needs someone to walk
alongside them and we're here for you
give me a call at 844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
or you can go to and again they keep
telling me to stop putting the www
because we don't need that anymore
but you do go to www.johndaloney.com
show and you can fill out the form let
us know what's going on and we will have
you on the show
and uh looking forward to it so we got a
packed house today we got a packed show
today so we're gonna get right to it but
before we uh before we go
right to it just gotta say this
it's like college shirt out here in the
lobby today
i'm looking at a guy with a purdue shirt
on you know what i instantly think
that guy's real smart he's super good
looking he's sitting next to a beautiful
young woman
he's smart and right in front of him
is a guy wearing an oklahoma football
shirt
you know what i think of that guy i'm
not even going to say it a
because he can probably beat me up in a
fight because i'm not very tough
b he's wearing a cowboy hat with
sunglasses on top which means he knows
something i don't know and a bandana
which is that's me how it's kind of
awesome
you're from texas right wearing an
oklahoma shirt
and he lives in kansas this is what we
call
we're going to talk about people with
this type of psychological confusion at
some point on the show
in the very near future but we're not
today we're going to go straight to the
phones let's go to keith in sacramento
california
keith what's up brother how we doing hey
john thank you so much for taking
the time to talk to me i really
appreciate it you got a man
just living the dream out here in
california thank you for calling
you're the first person i've talked to
in one calendar year that said the words
i'm living the dream here in california
so i'm glad you're keeping your chin up
man that's awesome
so uh how can i help man all right so
i'm a little concerned about the
situation between my brother
and my parents uh my brother's 32 years
old
he's got a professional job as an
accountant but he is still living at
home
and basically is showing no desire or
motivation to move out on his own
man how old are you i'm 35
35 yeah so what do you do
i'm a manager operations manager for a
healthcare company
okay um so uh yeah basically
you know at this point up until this
point i've kind of just stayed out of it
i haven't really
you know approached it with my parents
or approached it with my brother he's
been living at home basically since
college after moving out
um you know when he first graduated he
had a little bit of trouble finding you
know
his career job was was working and you
know so from a financial standpoint it
kind of made sense for him to move back
home
lives in the bay area really expensive
right um
but at this point you know he's been in
his career for five six years
makes good money saves his money money
is not a problem it's just like
doesn't want to leave and i'm kind of
i have concerns for him and his like
well-being of
you know yeah so why why why do you care
so you know he's i mean generally he's
he's really shy he like
has trouble making friends um so it's
not that he's a social butterfly where
he's got you know his own life and he's
just going there to crash
clearly especially with covid he's like
you know
he's not going to the office he's
working remotely so he doesn't really
have a whole lot going
on to like have any distractions um
and so that's my big concern is like i
mean i don't know if i don't
i don't think it would be good for him
just to live on his own i you know at
this point i'd say get some roommates
you know kind of build some friendships
have you talked to him
you know we don't have a super close
relationship i mean every time i try and
talk you know if we try and talk usually
it's like i get yes no answers so
like having you know to really try and
prod out of him is really difficult
it sounds
like i'm just going to tell you what it
sounds like it sounds like
you don't want him there for some reason
in your head and you've talked yourself
into some reasons
why he shouldn't be there um for his own
well-being
but this isn't a guy you're super close
to it's not a guy that you talk to very
regularly who or doesn't show any
interest in talking to you
so it sounds like you just want him to
get out and have to grow up and pay rent
and right now he's not having to go up
and pay rent and he's still eating
dinner with his mom and dad every night
sounds like you're a little bit jealous
is that fair or no
actually no um i you know
money situation not a problem my parents
everyday millionaires the financial
standpoint's not an issue there my
parents have helped me out financially
okay uh you know as my wife and i got
our you know first home and
and so what so what is this has been
super generous uh from a financial
standpoint
it's it's really i i truly have you know
i
i had an uncle that had some i don't
know if it was
mental health issues but you know he
just i think
really struggled in a similar way and so
i kind of see my brother but
not going the full-blown route that my
uncle did i mean he ended up not even
i think homeless you know that situation
but um i don't think he my brother would
get that to that point but i
i just feel like he's depressed and so
uh so here here's the only path forward
here
have you have you talked to your parents
what do they say
so i you know i've never really
approached it to my parents
we've talked about it a little bit you
know i was actually my parents were
visiting this past weekend and i was
talking to my dad and
you know he knows that and he i think he
wants him to you know get out and
you know have friends and and kind of
live his own life
um he wants his he wants to want his son
to want to go out but he's not going to
make it right right he exactly
and that and that's i think kind of the
challenge is you know he doesn't
my brother just doesn't i don't feel
have the the drive to do it
he's living rent free with awesome
parents who still pay for it i mean
and he's got nothing else going on you
know what i mean
in his head he's going to move out and
just be lonely here's the thing
all of this anything you do starts with
a
with an intimate vulnerable conversation
that's it
you haven't talked to your parents
full-on about it i think that'd be
a not a good way to go i think you
set up a conversation with your brother
directly and you can't do it over the
phone i mean this is the thing you're
gonna have to get together in person
and just talk to him say i love you
how's things going when's the last time
you told your brother i love you
there you go yeah that's the last time i
told my parents i loved him
fix that today dude hey listen i'm
telling you right now
i've sat with too many young people and
i'm saying you're 35 you're a young
person
whose parents pass away and they say
i didn't say it i'm just telling you
right now dude you didn't call for that
advice that one's free
tell your parents today hey by the way i
haven't told you on 30 years that i love
you i love you and don't write it don't
text especially don't text it
that's such a california thing to do
don't text it that's an oklahoma thing
no they don't have texting in oklahoma
that is just call them okay just call
them
and say hey i love you you gotta start
there with your brother
otherwise he's not gonna hear you
because what he doesn't need is a
lecture what he doesn't need is more
information
he's got his information in a
spreadsheet and it works out awesome
no pain no hurt no um
no rejection no rent no food
all into the bank he's winning in his
in the spreadsheet of his life what he
doesn't have is somebody who's gonna
help him learn what a relationship feels
like and looks like
and that means somebody's gonna have to
go first and say hey i love you
i'm your brother i don't tell you this i
should have
i kind of suck as a big brother for not
ever saying this to you
so i'm changing all of it right now i
need you to know that i love you and
you're my little brother
and i'm real real proud of you and i
think you're pretty awesome
that's how you start this conversation
otherwise every alarm he has is going to
go off when you start lecturing him on
what he needs to be doing with his life
where he needs to be going
what he should be doing you know what 32
year olds should be doing and here's the
thing i agree with you
if you're 32 you're making great money
and you're done with all of the
things mom need to help you with get
your own place man grow up that's what
you should be doing
but you can't start there with a guy
that you don't have a relationship with
and by the way he talks to you he
doesn't he's not interested in a
relationship with you
under the current terms of your
relationship which is
advice yes no yes yes no no no yes yes
it's like almost like a morse code
relationship start with i love you
tell him and then go from there that's
that i mean that's
it and then if he says i appreciate your
advice i'm not super interested in it
then um we're going to move on and we're
going to go on to the next
i mean that's all you can do about it
right and then i'll tell you
don't carry that demon around in your
heart man because it's going to just
weigh down your home your marriage your
relationship your kids all that kind of
stuff
it's just going to make it heavier and
heavier for you and um
there's no reason to carry that around
speak your piece tell your brother
you're here for him you love him you're
gonna be with him if he wants to help
you
you and your wife can go with him and
it's some new person on a double date
whatever it is you want to get involved
with
but it's going to be relational not
informational dude
i'm basically a rapper now and i'm going
to coin that informational not
relational
that's what he needs right um that's
where his heart and mind need to be
um so i appreciate you loving your
brother man
and but do this the right way and
say i love you and then go from there
all right let's go to joanna in
san antonio texas joanna what's going on
how can i help
hey thank you for taking my call for
sure what's going on
so um my uh my husband and i have been
married for six years
about three and a half years ago he
confessed to me
that he has been a cocaine addict
and an alcoholic since he was 13 years
old
and ever since then we've we've been
struggling with this
um like trying to get him free i guess
from addiction
so i was calling to see your opinion on
when is it
time to decide if he needs to go to
rehab
there's a lot there can i ask you a
couple of questions that i'm just
curious
about okay for sure um
i've been very close to folks who have
struggled with cocaine i've been very
close to folks who have struggled with
um alcohol i've been very close
with folks and worked with countless
numbers of
folks young people um through various
forms of addiction
how do you be married to somebody for
six years and not know they're a cocaine
addict and an alcoholic
okay well it was two and a half years
but for sure like i guess
it's because i i i have never been
around it
myself ever i you were super around it a
lot
you just didn't know you didn't know
that's what that was and i saw i i mean
looking back i'm like oh yeah it was
pretty much i just you know i would see
him
i well now it's like okay you were kind
of like detoxing
and you were crazy but i just didn't i
just let him
you know do whatever like he would be
angry and all this stuff but i was like
oh he's just an
angry person who cares and i just kind
of turned a blind eye to it really
and he never used in front of you once
in that many years
no no definitely not no how old are you
i'm uh 32 32.
so was that for 15 years
he's been a coke addict yes yeah
are you sure that's what that is
i was gonna say have you ever been
around a coke addict who's been a coke
addict for a decade
but you just said no you haven't
it's really
it's hard to be functional at this point
does he go to work every day
he works his brains out yeah
that's the deal he's a very functioning
cocaine alcoholic okay like
super he started his own business
was successful with it with a partner i
mean
so yeah he was very successful that's i
think why i just kind of didn't
think about it so yeah the dirty secret
about cocaine is that it works real good
it works real good you will outwork
people you will get a lot done
you will be a rock star in the way we've
set up society
and then everything around you falls
apart right it just melts underneath you
so what what brought about him telling
you um
that he had a problem
i think he at the time uh he just
he was just tired of it he just didn't
want it anymore and i think also
what happened was his childhood was
absolutely horrible
sure we've we confronted his parents
about it
and actually cut them out of our lives
because
they were that bad and then it was six
months after that that
he told me so i feel like it was because
he was dealing with that and he finally
was like
if i dealt with that and i'm throwing
off pretty much like the shackles of my
childhood
i need to deal with this like this is my
crutch and that is why i had the crutch
in the first place
yeah so i um
i'm gonna take a different tack than you
probably were thinking um
okay i'm heartbroken for your husband
because i know that's exhausting
and i know that um i don't say that
lightly cocaine works man it helps numb
stuff out it helps you get crap done it
helps you
get up and get to where you need to be
and get stuff done and get stuff done
it's a connection issue right and it
covers up for
a number of cracked and fractured and
broken
and hurting relationships um
and yeah it works until it doesn't and
when it doesn't it takes
down everyone around you right
and so um i'm just trying to put myself
in his head that man once i confront my
parents once i go through that gauntlet
then this is just gonna
i'm gonna be free of this and then he
tries month one and month two and month
three and then all of a sudden it gets
real scary because you can't stop
right and um so here's
here's three things i'm just thinking
here's three things you gotta
rattle around in your head okay tell me
if i'm on the mark here
number one harsh reality is someone you
love is hurting real bad is that right
yeah okay and they're hurting real bad
and they're a drug addict
is that right yes okay number two
you were lied to for a long time by
somebody you love
is that hurt there also yes yeah
okay and then the third hurt we often
don't think about
is there a part of you that can't fathom
this is the same question i asked you
right when when at the beginning of this
call how in the world you missed this
yes uh yeah i will see that
i was a single mother um when we got
married and i think that what it was was
i
i had struggled so long as a single mom
i was single mom for five years
and then i was like it's not like i was
looking for men but when i found him and
i was like oh my god this is the one
blah blah
yeah then it was like my battle's over
and i so it was just like
and you'll put up with anything just for
that security right yeah
yeah yeah exactly so i think that's what
was going
on is he at a place where he wants to go
to rehab
yes okay and actually it's a little
funny that i
i was kind of at a moment of despair um
and i sat down at the
computer and i went to your website and
i like typed in this message like my
husband is a cocaine addict thing and um
when is it time to decide to go to rehab
and i didn't send it
i was just in despair and i was like
whatever john delaine doesn't want to
hear this
and my husband saw it like hours later
and he sent
it for me oh wow like he does want
answers okay like he wants something
okay so um
the man my head was going in a totally
different direction
um so i'm gonna tell you i think i love
your husband
and i'm proud of him i'm not proud of
him for lying to you i'm not proud of
him
for deceiving those who love and care
for him i'm not
um but my heart's broken for him and so
i'm not gonna
beat him up if he was here i would hug
him and i'd hug him real real hard
okay when it's time to go to rehab is
when he
is ready to go and
until he's ready to go ultimatums
forcing if you don't do this then what
you're doing is your weaponizing
relationship your weaponizing connection
which is the one thing
that continues this drug use over and
over and over and over again
right yeah and so it's gonna sound like
i'm splitting hairs here but what you
have to do is you've gotta
develop strong boundaries not
walls not build walls right so you're
not building a wall to keep him from you
you are building boundaries to keep you
safe
and sometimes that boundary means you
got to go you got to get out of this
home that we've shared
sometimes boundaries mean no all the
time boundaries mean
you cannot have cocaine around my
children
period right yes so there's those type
of boundaries
are you physically and psychologically
safe
are you safe in your home environment
does he love you that way
yes okay so no harm no
scary nights no at the end of a four day
bender
and you know that that pinwheel eye i'm
talking about right when it is just
all bloodshot pinwheels and he can steer
a hole through you
um and he's checking the the peephole to
the curtains to the peephole back to the
curtains because he hasn't slept in 72
hours
you're safe in those moments
yes because he he really hasn't been
like that like he
he's super deceitful actually so he just
um has really just kept everything to
himself and the worst he's ever done is
just stayed up all night watching tv
and he's never it's never been violent
or anything like that or i
would have left a long time ago okay i
want you to make sure you've got
somebody that you can reach out to that
you can be safe with
the journey for him is going to be hard
and here's why i'm less concerned with
the cocaine i'm more concerned with
the childhood trauma that he's gonna
have to stare down
and to heal all the way across the board
he's gonna have to
walk that back and he's gonna have to
walk that back with a professional you
can't do that by herself
okay and so at some point
it's going to take the humility and the
character
and the desire to not feel like this
anymore the word i've heard over and
over with folks who struggle with
cocaine is i just got exhausted
i just couldn't like my soul was was
cleaned out right
and so um if he hit send
then i want you to to um then tonight's
the night
tomorrow's the morning right
the old um the old the old it's a
it's an old meditation saying but every
breath is a chance to start over
you don't wait till monday you don't
wait till next month when we figure out
if somebody's ready to go then you go
okay
okay okay um
i want you tonight to write him a letter
so he can have something in his hands
and i want that letter
i want you to let him know how much you
love him do you love him
yes okay i want you to be honest about
the deception
okay and i'm not i'm not beating him up
over cocaine i'm
i'm beating him up over don't lie to
your wife not the one woman who loves
you
okay right and let him know that you're
gonna be there
but let him know that you love him so
much you want him to
get well right okay
um and then you are going to need
someone to walk alongside you too
because when this thing peels off
there's going to be a lot a lot a lot a
lot of layers
okay yeah you're gonna go through some
seasons of being pissed off at yourself
for missing it you're gonna be pissed
off at him for lying to you the way he
has
you're gonna be upset at the way people
treated him when he was a kid
you're going to deal with your own
trauma which i know is there
and you all are going to have to
completely start over
and build a new marriage together okay
and that could be exciting and fun if
you have that kind of heart about it
and it can be devastating and scary if
you're trying to recreate
that guy that just came in you know the
the the shining armor
on the horseback right that saved
everything for you a few years ago
you all have to build something new and
you're going to have to get new skills
to learn how to do that
okay yes i'll also tell you this
you don't have the money for this but
you have to do it okay
yes right that might mean that you're
going to take a second job
that might mean that he's gonna have to
break down and call his employer
and go through the um employee
assistance program
he's gonna have to reach out to a local
church he's gonna have to get some help
from somebody
i don't know how that financially works
for you you can't not do this
okay okay okay for sure and um
i just want to tell you i'm grateful
that you love your husband
okay i'm grateful that you love him and
you are lucky lucky lucky that you're in
a safe situation
and um your job is to make sure those
babies are safe too
okay okay all right okay i'm proud of
you
um anybody listening to this
not for a second am i trying to condone
being a cocaine addict not for a second
am i trying to condone being an
alcoholic
not condoning any number of things okay
but until you have sat across from
someone who says i'm done i'm enough
enough then you don't know how
hard drug use is a connection issue man
and if you can look around for the last
40 50 years in this country we went to
war and we lost
because we tried to weaponize connection
we tried to weaponize the one thing that
people were dying from
which is a lack of relationship or
hurting relationships broken
relationships all over the place
trauma and what do we do we separated
them further from other people we
we we disconnected them even further
now i'm not saying she shouldn't be safe
you heard me say she's got to be safe
man
and sometimes that is i will not be in
relationship with you right now i love
you but you can't stay here i love you
but i'm not inviting you to christmas
i love you with all of my heart and i
will be there for you i'm not giving you
a penny
i'm not going to give you a dime but
i'll answer the phone when you call
i'm gonna send letters i'm gonna make
sure you know that you're loved
and when you're ready he hit send man he
hit send
so when is somebody ready to go to rehab
when they're ready to go to rehab
man i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
thinking about you guys joanna praying
for you to your husband who's watching
this listening to this
i'm proud of you but go go through the
whole program don't quit don't walk out
it's gonna get hard and then it's gonna
get harder
and then after
the hard then it's gonna get ugly
because you're gonna have to stare down
your childhood you're gonna have to
stare down your trauma you're gonna have
to let that little five-year-old boy
that's
been protecting you for so long you're
gonna have to let him
go play you have to let him just go play
and i want you to hold that letter that
joanna's gonna write you i want you to
read it over and over and over don't
forget that you're loved you're loved
you're loved
you got a lot of hard work ahead of you
but you're going to be free of this
thing
and then man the character of the guy
who built the business the character of
the guy who loves his wife
and he's going to tell her the truth
from this point forward he's never going
to lie again
there's nothing that's going to stop you
and you're going to be able to help that
guy that you work with you're going to
be able to help that woman that you work
with and you're going to be about
healing your community
instead of taking from it so man
i'm i'm with you guys joanna let me know
how that goes when you drop him off
for his inpatient program i want you to
reach back out to us and let us know how
that conversation goes
and we'll keep the um we'll keep our
listeners plugged into this one
thank you so much for trusting us um
yeah wow good for you guys all right i'm
gonna take a hard left turn
and um here's a couple of notes that
i've i received
from the internets and um so
so a couple of quick things a couple of
just teaching things
number one what are some of my favorite
books from 2020
here's uh four books if you're gonna
start 2021 we're a couple of months in
now here's a couple of books
four books you got to go pick up right
now okay
number one lost connections by johann
hari h-a-r-i
this is a thick book it's a lot it is
worth the read
it re-imagines depression i cheered
through this book i actually got kind of
frustrated because we're working on a
big book for me here and i was like
man i was gonna write that chapter i was
gonna write that man he he
johan hari does a remarkable job in this
book
pulling apart the strings of the way we
look at depression
the nonsensical way we've approached it
and um ways we can get well it's an it's
a it's a world-class master craft
class book it is a long read and it's
tough to get through sometimes it's
dense
it is worth your time another book by dr
nadine
burke harris called the deepest well
this is a shorter book
it is a masterpiece every
single person in the world should read
the books called the deepest well
about adverse childhood experiences aces
man we are all carrying them around and
this book is an
eye-opener it's extraordinary i had the
opportunity to do some uh work with some
uh do some aces work with kids at one of
my practicums several years ago
this book is the master class dr burke
harris is
it's an extraordinary book it's an easy
read it's good to get through she does a
great job
teaching the science it's good it's good
get it
also you're going to think this is a a
hard turn it's
not jocko williamsburg book
discipline equals freedom so we're going
from a
a deep deep dive into the etiology the
history of depression
where we even get what we where it even
comes from
the deepest well childhood traumas and
then a book that says
and tomorrow you got to wake up and
decide
and i read through jocko's book and i
kept thinking
yeah yeah and so we do have childhood
traumas we do have hard hard things we
do have
have painful experiences in our life
and we got to wake up tomorrow morning
and just
make a good next decision and jocko's
book makes me laugh it's hard
it made me um have to re-examine some of
the excuses i make in my everyday life
and i have made some direct life changes
because of these three books
then the fourth book was from a previous
show my good friend rachel cruz's book
know your money know yourself
know yourself no your money that's right
now yourself know your money
man i have sat with couples in a
counseling session i've sat with people
in counseling type sessions or coaching
sessions
they will tell me about their sex life
they will tell me about
the the times they betrayed their own
values
the times they betrayed values of other
people and they will not talk about
their money
they won't talk about their debt they
won't talk about their fear
behind money scarcity i'm never gonna
have enough
and we have this thing baked into our
culture listen when i say this
we have distilled down what a person's
value is
with this one question hey what are you
worth
and we put a number on that question and
we wonder why it's hard
for people to talk about money right
because we ask
all these things what are the vacations
you didn't go on how big your house is
how what kind of cars you drive what
colleges you did or didn't go to
all that distills down to hey what are
you worth
and we put a dollar amount on that
question the answer to the question
what are you worth is never a dollar
amount
but we do it in rachel's book
it is a a quick it's not a quick read
it's a
it's a thick book but it's not a deep
science book but it is an extraordinary
look
at here's where your money story that
you've told yourself that you were born
into here's where it comes from and
here's why you struggle with it the way
you do
the millions of americans
that can't miss a paycheck or their
bills don't get paid
the millions of america that can't
handle a 400
emergency right
man a lot of that's deep rooted in the
stories we tell ourselves so those are
the four books i would say go pick those
up and go get after them lost
connections the deepest wealth
discipline equals freedom
and know yourself know your money those
are awesome all right i'm gonna do the
next teaching segment on the next show
it's about sleep so stay tuned for the
next show on sleep i'm gonna get to this
last call here let's go to emilia
in houston texas amelia what's going on
how can i help
hey dr john how are you i'm doing so
good how about you
i'm good okay hey wait hold on
you just said you gave me a long good
which usually is a nice way of saying
not very good at
all i i mean i'm
i'm struggling if i'm being honest there
we go all right we tell the truth on
this show amelia
all right so hey what's up so
i am a
wife a mom of two um
a six-year-old and a two-year-old and
i am a neonatal nurse um
oh honey amelia
that's a lot i don't even know why
you're calling that's a lot
um so i absolutely love
my job um i
i feel like it is where
i am meant to be it's my
it's my passion it's my work um and it's
um but also so it's a mom right
so i guess that's where my struggle is
is
i feel like i'm where i'm supposed to be
and what i'm supposed to be
doing but i don't want my kids and my
family to suffer
um based on the choices of my career
um and i'm just i guess i'm just
struggling with finding a balance
between it all
um and that struggle between
you know i'm i'm doing what i know i'm
supposed to be doing like it feels right
i'm
happy i'm um
but then you know my kids aren't in bed
at
you know 8 30 and they're you know
there's not really a set
schedule i guess that's the best way to
put it um
and so um i guess to complicate things
my six-year-old
has recently been diagnosed with adhd
and so just making sure that he has that
balance and that he feels
that you know mom and dad are here for
them
no matter what um
how's your how's your marriage
our marriage is great um what does that
mean um
what is great so i have full support
from my husband
and he wants to
um you know make sure that i'm happy and
that
you know he's fully supportive of
me working and um
doing what we've both worked so hard for
um to get to this point i mean we have
good communication we are working on
that um but i do feel like that has
improved
um we are seeing a actual counselor
um since my son was diagnosed we want it
to be on the same page as far as
um how we handle different situations
and scenarios and things like that so i
feel like
the openness is there and he has long
work hours as well
he's a an emergency veterinarian so he
also has
long hours and hard days
but i do feel like that communication's
there i feel like
um i can trust him he is my best friend
like he's the one that i
that i want to do life with um so
i know so
there's a lot here give me a specific
question how can i help you
um i guess just how do i
how how do i take the negativity from
coming in from the outside of saying
that
i guess from family members that mean
well
um saying that you know my children are
suffering because they're
the hours that my husband and i work and
you know having the
um
i i'm sorry no it's okay so let me do
this i'm gonna start
walking this back and you feel free to
cut me off and jump in at any time
okay sure and my promise to you as a
fellow houstonian
even if you were from mars i would be
honest with you is i'm going to tell you
the truth the truth and nothing but the
truth
so help me god okay um
your life sounds chaotic is that a good
word
that's pretty accurate okay it's not a
bad thing it just sounds like it is
right and it would be chaotic because
you have a six and a two-year-old just
be on just because of that right six and
two-year-olds are a lot they're all over
the place
and they're fun and beautiful and
wonderful and oh my gosh if i can't
sleep a whole night right so they're all
of it right all the same time
right that's number one number two
i've got two people
deeply committed to traumatic
professions
who love one another and are trying to
make that work okay
yes sir and when you are a don't say sir
so y'all both deal in trauma every day
people come to you in their worst
moments and say
please help me please save my baby
please save my um this
animal that this pet of mine that has
this is all i've got
right and that is a lot every day
and y'all i know y'all know that but
sometimes it helps for somebody else to
say it out loud
y'all deal in other people's hurt
okay and what people come to you and say
everything in my world is dark please
turn a light on somehow some way
right and then you've got
so you got two little kids you got chaos
no matter what you got two people who
deal in trauma every day
right and then
you are trying to make all this work at
all at the same time
and then somebody comes and drops
something in your lap that says hey your
six-year-old
has a chaos connection
learning disorder which is adhd which is
a
another way to frame it and i get a lot
of grief for it and i don't care
um i'm a card-carrying member i'm off
the chart by the way
like um i i on the scoring it's comical
okay um so the hard reality is
if we look at adhd as a connection issue
as a
response to chaos a learned response to
chaos
and also the nonsensical educational
environment some of our kids are forced
into
right then you you start to reverse
engineer your life
and it gets hard and then people start
throwing their little comment grenades
at you
right um they start telling you things
that cut you right into your soul as
though they're helping and they're not
because these are all things that you
know
right and so here's what i'm going to
super strong recommend you do okay
what i'm telling you right now is you
are on a recipe for
complete and total burnout and i think
probably both of you are you and your
husband
and the problem with the burnout is you
don't know where it's going to land
whether it's going to be relational
burnout
whether it's going to be professional
burnout whether it's going to be burned
out on those kids
okay and i'm telling you that twofold
number one
i have lived the life you were talking
about right now okay
with the only difference is my wife
didn't work in trauma she was a
professor
she didn't work a sh i didn't have two
rows or two of us working in trial
there's just one of us okay
so here's my recommendation are you
ready this is the prescription from a
non-medical
guy you ready yeah i want you
in to start in reverse order
none of this works none of it
unless you and your husband prioritize
your marriage number one above your kids
above your
work above all of it okay okay
and so that starts with you all two
getting together and being real
vulnerable with each other
being really direct letting him know
what you need from him what you need
just
period letting him tell you what he
needs
what are things that y'all can do for
one another to help you guys be whole
because you'll have to be whole because
you're dealing with so much secondary
traumatic stress
and you can only repel off and hold
another mom whose baby is in nicu
you can only repel off and hold another
baby and another baby
and another baby when you are fully
anchored in
okay um so number one you've got to
give him permission to hold you
accountable to whatever you all agree to
you're gonna have to let him um speak
into your life and you're
he's going to let you speak into his
life and what does that look like that
means you're going to have to be honest
about what you eat
how much you'll move and exercise are
y'all getting sleep are y'all taking
care of yourselves
are you putting your oxygen mask on
first to beat an old metaphor to death
right only then can you then
focus on those two beautiful angels that
you brought into the world
and they come next right what are the
boundaries with kids what are the ways
that mom and dad are dealing with our
secondary traumatic stress
um i'm so glad to hear you all say hey
we just got
some new information our kids got adhd
so we're gonna go to counseling to make
sure we have the tools to connect with
one another we're on the same page
that's so awesome amelia
that that was your default good for you
but
what is the way we're gonna be connected
with these kids
and then and only then does
our professional life come after that
okay
and you said something that i wrote down
here
we worked so hard to get somewhere
and you got there and i want to tell you
i've done research
i've met with i can't even tell you how
many doctors
lawyers fancy pants preachers
college presidents senior staff at
universities across the country
and i can't tell you how many times i've
heard the line
i worked so hard to get here and then
they have to ask themselves
was it worth it i worked so hard to get
here but i just want to play with my kid
i worked so hard to get here but i never
see my wife i work
so hard to get here and fill in the
blank
and you can all every time you can i say
the following words you don't have to
keep doing this job
and you can almost see their shoulders
just drop as they never even considered
that
or they will say really quickly no no i
want to do this job and i love it when
they say that too
because now i know what's important
right your marriage your kids
your job but we're going to do it in
that order
and we're going to not give on these
priorities that we say we're not going
to give on and then we know we're in it
right
and that way when you come home
exhausted you can text your husband at
four o'clock in the afternoon
and say i'm having a day and it's
my ranking score is a seven and he knows
all right i got dinner tonight
i got kids bath tonight and i'm all in
or you can text him and say today was a
two and he's like
sweet she's got dinner i've got one kid
she's got the other we're gonna divide
and conquer whatever
system you all come up with but it's got
to go in that order does that make sense
yes is that frustrating to hear
or is it a relief to hear
um i think it's what i've been telling
myself
okay um i guess
um and i think that's a struggle
as i know where the priority should be
um
and um
i guess it's just it's a struggle of
finding what's the right answer because
you know here's the writing yes the
hours the right answers
your relationship and your kids and your
work in that order
because one doesn't work without the
other if you were single
yeah dude you're all in on this nike gig
and i would still be telling you you got
to prioritize you
your psychological and spiritual mental
health above the nike job because you're
no good to those kids if you're fried
and burnt out
you're no good to those mothers and
fathers who are so desperately clinging
on to
every last shred of hope you're no good
to them
if you're not good if you're not whole
at home right
and if were a single mom i would tell
you your health comes first your brain
and your heart come first
those kids come second work comes third
and you tethered yourself to a guy that
sounds like he's a great guy
he's a good man he's deals with trauma
for a living he helps other people he
loves you he loves your kids
and so he comes first and then when
you're tethered in there then you can
anchor off
and be the mom and dad that you all are
going to be that you know you've got
that picture in your head what that's
going to look like
and then and only then can you be the
trauma nurse
that those families desperately need you
to be
that what i want to give you permission
is just to drop your shoulders
and go we got a lot going on and it may
be
that for this season he doesn't work
overnight shifts
because you got a six and a two year old
and
maybe for the next three years
he is just doing the day shift and he
just he goes off call and it's gonna
hammer you all financially and it sucks
but those kids are worth the time
or maybe for the next two years you
don't work night shifts you work day
shifts and you're not
doing weekend plugs whatever that looks
like but give yourselves permission to
go in that
order most couples try to reverse
engineer it how many hours can we shave
off and not have to do this
i want you all to start the other way i
love you
so much and here's what you bring to me
you don't even know
what you bring to me how much i love and
here's what i desperately need from you
what can i help with you so that you and
i can work together
and then man what do we want our kids
worlds to look like what do we
what kind of picture do we want to what
we want home to look like
and you said it best man kids are
routine
sponges bedtimes every night
at this time even if it cuts into mom
and dad time
they're gonna get their bedtime here
they're gonna eat here
they're gonna we're gonna all get up
together or i'm gonna go do my
morning routine dad's gonna do wake ups
on this week and i'm gonna flip it
whatever that looks like but you're
gonna map that out
and then you'll figure out the work
stuff later and if you're an awesome
nike nurse
i guarantee you are and your work
doesn't accommodate that there's a
hundred different places in houston
texas where you can go be an iq nurse
there just is and if your husband's
practice is no bro you
you got to do there's a hundred there's
a thousand places in
in houston where he can go be an awesome
vet with that kind of expertise and that
kind of experience and the kind of
compassionate heart that he has
so you're not locked in you just got to
go in the right order
i am so proud of you as a couple i'm
proud of you emilia
for thinking through this i'm so
grateful that there are
incredible smart brilliant compassionate
women like you out there taking care of
these babies
taking care of these families who are
have a baby who are struggling
every moment of their life has been
rocked upside down so glad you're doing
this
and i'm so glad you're a mom who loves
your kids and then you're a wife who
loves her husband
and also don't forget you got a six and
a two-year-old everything feels like the
end of time when you have a six and a
two-year-old
there should be a youtube series just
for parents of six and two-year-olds
called it gets better
i know there's a couple of different
series it gets better i'm telling you
you got a six and two year old it gets
better
it does it does it does i'm so
grateful you have uh we're gonna end the
show there man i i just love talking to
you it's awesome
um all right so as we wrap up today's
show
this isn't the greatest song of all time
it's brand new it hasn't been out long
enough but it's gonna be
and i'm gonna tell you right now i'm a
sucker for a
heartfelt a heartfelt
teen young 20s
30s piano ballad
that just tears at this at the soul and
this is it man
it's off the i think it's the or1 record
is that it
olivia rodrigo man
here's the words of this incredible song
i got my driver's license last week just
like we always talked about
because you were so excited for me to
finally drive up to your house but today
i drove through the suburbs crying
because you weren't around oh my gosh i
can feel it and you're probably with
that blonde girl
come on man who always made me doubt
she's so much
older than me she's everything i'm
insecure about today i drove through the
suburbs because
how could i ever love someone else and i
know we weren't perfect but i never felt
this way for no one and i just can't
imagine
how could you be so okay now that i'm
guess you didn't mean what you wrote in
that song about me because you said
forever now i drive alone
past your street oh my gosh can you hear
that line i'm gonna do that again
guess you didn't mean what you wrote in
that song about me because you said
forever now i drive alone past your
street
olivia rodrigo this is the dr john
dolone show
[Music]
you